hey Oscar impress my name's Peter Pan my
hair looks like an octopus that's always
a good thing
we played Adam Sandler dating simulator
and boy was that an experience that made
me question my sexuality today however
we're playing an even better game trust
me
you guessed it Nicolas Cage similar a
dating simulator caging me softly got
great reviews we have a quote from Obama
that says this gave me half a boner
don't tell Michelle
uh okay so let's just begin here we are
it's Friday morning and school was
already in the process but as usual I
need in my morning coffee so that my
brain can function normally I was on my
way to the coffee shop when I saw
someone very very familiar wait oh my
god everyone stared at me like I was
crazy
he placed a finger on his lips this is
very sexual I like it then he winked at
me
I can't believe it what is Nicolas Cage
doing here he had always been my
favorite actor and not to mention your
faces your shoes I liked them
fabulous magnificent beautiful fabulous
I know right sir you have been my
favorite actor right
don't call me sir call me daddy oh it's
gonna be good and so they made love all
night long and had beautiful children
crying rillette what the [ __ ] are you
kidding me
that was it best what did I say what did
I say best simulator game ever let's try
that again I love the music by the way
it's so nice your face is beautiful I'm
beautiful
why thank you sir
I love you from the moment I set my eyes
on you I just knew you were so beautiful
from the inside II and the outside and
that I needed your babies you those are
the most wonderful words anyone's ever
said to me
come let us commence the baby making
progress congratulations you got the
romantic ending I like that one I think
I like that one a little better oh my
god I can't wait to try all the endings
your face is magnificent I hope you like
unicorn sir you are by far my favorite
actor ever Ken Rhea
uh what is it jack what is it jack spit
it out next thing you knew everything
turned black where am I
worried what worried nut I have passed
you pass out earlier so I dragged your
body to the hospital mr. cage thank you
and so he cage your heart softly
congratulations do you got the good
ending I don't know why I want to rub my
body in in oil all right let's do the
last ending okay what do we got your
shoes I like them uh thanks
I um I need to go no don't leave me I
grabbed his arm with all my mind what
let me go at once no I love you
somebody help someone from the coffee
shop called the police and you were
arrested you went crazy in your prison
cell and swore to get Nicolas Cage with
you in the cage better luck next time
bad ending